para saber su opinión.
Así es como llegué a almorzar con cientólogos.
Un hombre llamado Brian
dirige un equipo estrella de cientólogos
decidido a destruir la psiquiatría dondequiera que aparezca.
Se les conoce como la CCDH.
Y le pregunté: "¿Puedes demostrarme
que la psiquiatría es una paraciencia en la que no se puede confiar?"
Y él contestó: "Sí, podemos demostrárselo".
Y yo: "¿Cómo?"
Y él: "Le presentaré a Tony".
Y yo: "¿Quién es Tony?"
Y él: "Tony está en Broadmoor".
Ahora es el hospital de Broadmoor.
Antes era conocido como el manicomio de Broadmoor para criminales dementes.
El lugar adonde envían a los asesinos en serie
y a las personas que no pueden ayudarse a sí mismas.
Y pregunté a Brian, "¿Qué hizo Tony?"
Y él: "Casi nada.
Él golpeó a alguien o algo,
y decidió fingir locura para salir de la cárcel.
Pero fingió tan bien que ahora está atrapado en Broadmoor
y nadie creerá que no está loco.
¿Quieres que vayamos a Broadmoor para encontrarnos con Tony?"
Y yo: "Sí, por favor".
Así que fuimos en tren a Broadmoor.
Comencé a bostezar incontroladamente a la altura de Kempton Park,
que al parecer es lo que hacen los perros cuando están ansiosos,
bostezan sin control.
Y llegamos a Broadmoor.
Y me llevaron a través de una puerta, otra puerta y otra
hasta el centro de salud y bienestar,
donde se pueden conocer a los pacientes.
Parece un hotel Hampton gigante.
Todo en madera de pino y durazno con colores relajantes.
Y los únicos colores llamativos son los rojos de los botones de emergencia.
Y los pacientes comenzaron a deambular sin rumbo.
Tenían bastante sobrepeso, pantalones de entrenamiento
además de un aspecto bastante dócil.
Y Brian, el cientólogo, me susurró:
"Están medicados",
que para los cientólogos es lo peor del mundo,
y yo creo que quizá sea una buena idea hacerlo.
(Risas)
Y Brian dijo: "Aquí está Tony".
Un hombre venía caminando.
No tenía sobrepeso, tenía una muy buena condición física.
Y no llevaba pantalones de entrenamiento,
llevaba puesto un traje de raya diplomática.
Y tenía su brazo extendido
como alguien del programa "El aprendiz".
Parecía un hombre que deseaba usar una indumentaria
para convencer de que era muy cuerdo.
Y él se sentó.
Y pregunté: "¿Así que es cierto que fingió su camino hasta llegar aquí?"
Y dijo: "Sí. Así es exactamente. Golpeé a alguien cuando tenía 17 años.
Y cuando estaba en prisión en espera de juicio,
mi compañero de celda me dijo:
"¿Ya sabes lo que tienes que hacer?
Pues hacerte el loco".
Diles que estás loco. Te enviarán a algún hospital cómodo.
Las enfermeras te traerán pizzas.
Y tendrás tu propia Playstation".
Así que pregunté: "Bueno, ¿cómo lo hiciste?"
Él dijo: "Pedí por el psiquiatra de la prisión.
Acababa de ver una película llamada 'Crash'
donde las personas obtienen placer sexual al estrellar autos contra las paredes.
Así que dije al psiquiatra,
'Tengo placer sexual al estrellar autos contra las paredes".
Y yo: "¿Y qué más?"
Él: "Sí. Le dije al psiquiatra
que quería ver a las mujeres como morían
porque eso me haría sentir más normal".
Y yo: "¿De dónde sacaste eso?"
Él: "De una biografía de Ted Bundy
que tenían en la biblioteca de la prisión".
Y explicó que fingió la locura demasiado bien.
Así que no lo enviaron a un hospital cómodo.
Lo enviaron a Broadmoor.
Y desde el momento que llegó ahí,
tras haber echado un vistazo al lugar, pidió ver al psiquiatra,
y le dijo: "Ha habido un terrible malentendido.
Yo no soy un enfermo mental".
Le pregunté: "¿Cuánto tiempo llevas aquí?"
Él: "Bueno, si hubiera cumplido el tiempo de condena en la cárcel por el delito original,
habría pasado cinco años.
Ya llevo en Broadmoor 12 años".
Tony dijo que es mucho más difícil convencer a la gente de que estás cuerdo
que de convencer que estás loco.
Él: "Pensé que la mejor manera de parecer normal
sería hablar con la gente normalmente sobre cosas normales
como el fútbol o sobre lo que dan en la televisión.
Estoy suscrito a la revista New Scientist,
y recientemente se publicó un artículo
acerca de cómo el Ejército de EEUU entrenaba abejorros para detectar explosivos.
Así que le dije a una enfermera,
"¿Sabía Ud. que el Ejército de EEUU entrena abejorros
para detectar explosivos?"
Cuando leí las anotaciones médicas sobre mí,
vi que había escrito:
"Cree que las abejas pueden oler explosivos".
Él: "Siempre observan aspectos externos
para obtener pistas no verbales de mi estado mental.
Pero, ¿cómo se sienta uno de una forma cuerda?
¿Cómo cruzar las piernas de una manera sana?
Es simplemente imposible".
Y cuando Tony me dijo eso,
me pregunté a mí mismo: "¿Estoy sentado como un periodista?
¿Cruzo las piernas como un periodista?"
Él dijo: "Sabe, tengo al estrangulador de Stockwell a un lado
y al violador de los tulipanes al otro.
Por eso, tiendo a permanecer mucho en mi habitación porque me parecen bastante aterradores.
Y eso se considera como un signo de locura.
Dicen que eso demuestra que soy distante y ambicioso".
Así que sólo en Broadmoor el no querer pasar el rato con asesinos en serie
es un signo de locura.
A mí me parecía completamente normal, pero ¿qué sabía yo?
Y cuando llegué a casa le envié un correo a su médico Anthony Maden.
Le pregunté: "¿Cuál es la historia?"
Y él contestó, "Sí. Aceptamos que Tony fingió locura para zafarse de una pena de prisión
porque en primer lugar las alucinaciones les habían parecido bastante estereotipadas
y que desaparecieron en el momento de llegar a Broadmoor.
Sin embargo, lo evaluamos.
Y determinamos que es un psicópata".
Y de hecho, fingir locura
es exactamente el tipo de acto astuto y manipulador de un psicópata.
Está en la lista de verificación: astuto y manipulador.
Así que fingir que tu cerebro no funciona bien
es la evidencia de que el cerebro funciona mal.
Y he hablado con otros expertos,
y me dijeron que el traje de rayas es de psicópata clásico.
Hablan de uno o dos elementos en la lista de verificación:
falta de sinceridad, encanto superficial y gran sentido de autoestima.
Y dije: "Bueno, ¿pero por qué él no quería pasar el rato con los otros pacientes?"
De psicópata típico, pues muestra de superioridad y falta de empatía.
Así que todas las cosas que me parecían más normales de Tony
eran una prueba, según su médico,
de que estaba loco en esa nueva manera.
Él era un psicópata.
Y su médico me dijo:
"Si quiere saber más sobre psicópatas,
vaya a un curso para detectar psicópatas
impartido por Robert Hare quien inventó la lista de verificación del psicópata".
Y así lo hice.
Fui a un curso de detección de psicópatas,
y ahora ya tengo el certificado,
muy sobresaliente
de detector de psicópatas.
Así que aquí presento las estadísticas:
una de cada 100 personas normales es psicópata.
Aquí en esta sala hay 1500 personas, así que
15 de Uds. son psicópatas.
Aunque la cifra se eleva a 4%
entre los presidentes y directivos de empresas.
Así que creo que existe una gran probabilidad
de que haya entre 30 y 40 psicópatas en esta sala.
Podría haber una masacre al final de la noche.
(Risas)
Hare dijo que la razón se fundamenta en que el capitalismo en su forma más cruel
recompensa comportamientos psicopáticos,
la falta de empatía, la falta de sinceridad,
la astucia y la manipulación.
De hecho, el capitalismo, tal vez en su forma más despiadada,
es una manifestación física de la psicopatía.
Es como una forma de psicopatía
que ha llegado a afectar a todos.
Y Hare me dijo: "¿Sabes qué? Olvídate de alguien de Broadmoor
que puede o no haber fingido locura.
¿A quién le importa? Eso no es una gran historia.
La gran historia", dijo, "es la psicopatía empresarial.
¿Quieres ir a entrevistar tú mismo a psicópatas empresariales?".
Así que lo intenté. Le escribí a la gente de Enron.
Le dije: "¿Puedo ir y entrevistarles en la cárcel
para averiguar si Uds. son psicópatas?"
Y no contestaron.
Así que cambié de táctica.
Envié un correo electrónico a Dunlap alias "Motosierra",
el depurador de activos de los 90.
Llegaba a empresas en crisis y echaba al 30% de los empleados,
simplemente convirtió ciudades estadounidenses en pueblos fantasmas.
Y le escribí por correo electrónico y le dije:
"Creo que posiblemente tenga una anomalía cerebral muy especial
lo que le hace especial
e interesado por su espíritu depredador e intrépido.
¿Puedo ir a entrevistarle
acerca de esa anomalía cerebral especial?"
Y él dijo: "Venga".
Así que me fui a Florida a la gran mansión de Al Dunlap
que estaba llena de esculturas de animales depredadores.
Había leones y tigres.
Él me condujo a través del jardín.
Había halcones y águilas.
Él me decía: "Allá hay tiburones".
Esto lo decía de una manera menos afeminada.
"Hay más tiburones y más tigres".
Era como Narnia.
(Risas)
Y luego nos fuimos a la cocina.
A Dunlap le encargaron salvar empresas en quiebra.
Se deshizo de un 30% de los trabajadores.
Y él muy a menudo despedía a la gente con una broma.
Por ejemplo, hay una famosa historia sobre él,
alguien se le acercó y le dijo: "Acabo de comprarme un auto nuevo".
Y él dijo: "Ud. puede que tenga un auto nuevo,
pero le diré que no tiene trabajo".
Así que en su cocina, él estaba de pie allí con su esposa, Judy,
y con Sean, su guardaespaldas, y dije: "¿Recuerda lo que le dije a Ud. en el e-mail
que pueda que tenga una anomalía cerebral especial que le hace especial?"
Él dijo: "Sí, es una teoría increíble.
Es como Star Trek. Ud. llega allí donde ningún hombre ha ido antes".
Y yo dije: "Bueno, algunos psicólogos podrían decir
que esto le convierte ... "(Murmullos)
(Risas)
Y él: "¿En qué?"
Y yo: "En un psicópata".
Y añadí: "Tengo una lista de rasgos psicopáticos en el bolsillo.
¿Puedo repasarlos con Ud.?"
Y se mostró intrigado muy a su pesar,
y dijo: "Está bien, adelante".
Y yo: "De acuerdo. Sentido exagerado de autoestima".
Lo que habría sido difícil para él negar
porque estaba de pie debajo de una pintura al óleo gigante de sí mismo.
(Risas)
Él dijo: "Bueno, ¡tienes que creer en ti!"
Y yo: "Manipulación".
Él: "Eso es liderazgo".
Y yo: "Afectividad superficial:
la incapacidad de experimentar una serie de emociones".
Él: "¿Quién quiere abrumarse por emociones sin sentido?"
Así que él iba a través de la lista de verificación psicopática,
básicamente convirtiéndola en "¿Quién se ha llevado mi queso?"
(Risas)
Pero me di cuenta de algo que me pasó el día que estuve con Al Dunlap.
Cada cosa que él decía me resultaba que era normal,
como cuando dijo que no a la delincuencia juvenil.
Dijo que fue aceptado en West Point,
y no aceptan a delincuentes en West Point.
Él dijo que no a las relaciones de pareja a corto plazo.
Él sólo ha estado casado dos veces.
Es cierto que su primera esposa mencionó en los documentos de su divorcio
que una vez la amenazó con un cuchillo
y dijo que siempre tuvo la curiosidad por el sabor de la carne humana,
pero que en malos matrimonios las personas se dicen cosas estúpidas en el calor de una discusión
y que su segundo matrimonio ha durado 41 años.
Así que todo lo que me decía me pareció una suerte de no psicopatía.
Y me dije, no añadiré eso en mi libro.
Y entonces me di cuenta de que al convertirme en un detector de psicópatas
me había vuelto un poco psicópata.
Porque estaba desesperado por meterle en un casillero marcado como psicópata.
Yo estaba desesperado por definirle en base a sus límites más descabellados.
Y me di cuenta, Dios mío. Esto es lo que he hecho durante 20 años.
Es lo que todos los periodistas hacen.
Viajamos por todo el mundo con nuestros blocs de notas en la mano,
y esperamos a las joyas.
Y las joyas son siempre los aspectos más externos
de la personalidad de nuestro entrevistado.
Y las ensamblamos como los monjes medievales.
Y dejamos al margen las cosas normales.
Y este es un país que sobrediagnostica tremendamente ciertos trastornos mentales
Infancia bipolar. A niños de cuatro años
se les etiqueta de bipolares
porque tienen rabietas,
que alcanzan la puntuación más alta en la lista bipolar.
Al regresar a Londres, Tony me llamó por teléfono.
Él dijo: "¿Por qué no has respondido a mis llamadas?"
Le dije: "Bueno, dicen que eres un psicópata".
Y él dijo: "Yo no soy un psicópata".
Él dijo: "Sabes que uno de los puntos de la lista es la falta de remordimiento,
pero otro elemento en la lista de verificación es ser astuto y manipulador.
Así que cuando uno dice que siente remordimientos por su delito,
ellos dicen: Típico del psicópata
al decir astutamente que uno siente remordimientos cuando no es cierto'.
Es como un maleficio. Ellos dan a todo la vuelta".
Él dijo: "Tengo un tribunal pronto.
¿Quieres acompañarme?"
Le dije que sí.
Así que fui a su tribunal.
Y tras 14 años en Broadmoor, lo dejaron marchar.
Decidieron que no le debían retener indefinidamente
aunque las puntuaciones altas en una lista de verificación
significaran que podría tener una mayor probabilidad de reincidencia que el promedio.
Así que lo dejaron ir.
Y fuera, en el pasillo, me dijo:
"¿Sabes qué, Jon?
Todo el mundo es un poco psicópata".
Él dijo: "Tú lo eres. Yo lo soy. Bueno, obviamente yo soy".
Le pregunté: "¿Qué harás ahora?"
Él: "Iré a Bélgica
porque hay una mujer allí que me gusta.
Pero está casada, así que tendré que conseguir que se separe de su marido".
(Risas)
De todos modos, eso sucedió hace dos años,
y ahí es donde mi libro termina.
Y durante los últimos 20 meses, todo iba bien.
Nada malo ha pasado.
Él vivía con una chica fuera de Londres.
Estaba, según Brian el cientólogo,
recuperando el tiempo perdido; que sé que suena inquietante,
pero no es necesariamente inquietante.
Desafortunadamente, después de 20 meses,
tuvo que volver a la cárcel un mes.
Tuvo una pelea en un bar,
y acabo yendo a la cárcel un mes,
que sé que es malo,
pero al menos un mes que implica que toda la riña
no había sido tan nefasta.
Y entonces él me llamó.
Y me parece bien que Tony esté fuera.
Porque no se debe definir a las personas por sus aspectos más descabellados.
Y Tony es un semipsicópata.
Es un área gris en un mundo al que no le gustan las áreas grises.
Pero en las áreas grises es donde se encuentra la complejidad,
que es donde se encuentra la humanidad
y es donde se encuentra la verdad.
Y Tony me dijo:
"Jon, ¿puedo invitarte a una copa en un bar?
Sólo quiero darte las gracias por todo lo que has hecho por mí".
Y no fui. ¿Qué habría hecho Ud.?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)